لقد اكتشفنا الآن الحالة الأولى
قادمة من إيران والتي
أصبحت للأسف واحدة من
البلدان المتضررة ونعتقد أنك
تعلم بسبب هذا التأثير في إيران ،
فلدينا تقريبًا تأثير الآن في المنطقة
ونرى أنها أصبحت منتشرة على نطاق واسع
الفيروس في العالم بأسره
لكننا جهزنا كل شيء في جميع
مرافق الرعاية الصحية
لاستقبال الحالات التي تقدمنا فيها ول
ن أيضًا التأكد من عز
هم عن المجتمع وع
م تأثر البلد على نطاق وا
ع  إنها وجهة نظر الحكومة في
الوقت الحالي حول مدى سوء تأثير ذلك
اقتصاديًا على مستوى العالم
كمحور مهم لشركات الطيران ، حيث
ساعدت بلدانهم التي تعرفها في جعل نفسها وجهة سياحية
بالإضافة إلى ما ترى أن هذا
النوع من التأثيرات على نطاق أوسع ليس
فقط  أنت على الصعيد الإقليمي على الصعيد العالمي ، ما مدى حجم
تقييمك لهذا الأمر بالتأكيد
سيكون هناك تأثير بدأنا نراه
في الأيام والأسابيع القليلة الماضية
وقد رأينا  mpact في الأسواق المالية ،
لقد رأينا تأثيرًا على سوق السفر
على النفط على كل شيء
وجميع الجوانب ، لكننا نعتقد أن هذه
ستكون دورة لأن الفيروس
نفسه يحد من السفر عند حدود
يغلق الكثير من أماكن العمل  الكثير من
المصانع التي تؤثر على
أداء الشركات ولكن هذا
لن يستمر إلى الأبد أعني
بالتأكيد أنه سيكون هناك وقت نرى فيه
احتواء للفيروس
وطريقة لهزيمته وسنرى أيضًا
ارتفاع السوق مرة أخرى